back off my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
the ridge it was the lays that have
ridges in them they don't have that is
that not ladies no that's ruffles oh I
like the ruffles
they cut the top top of my mouth ruffles
is my nickname when I was a kid really
yeah I'm gonna bring you back huh
ruffles what do you call you did uh I
think cuz I was just like a roughly
little guy just over here ruffle your
this is gonna ruffle you look Brandon
looks like you want his outfit in the
skeeball dude you look like every Panama
City Florida lesbian porn this week a
transgender revenue hotdog eating
contest all right don't talk until the
whistle on the same if one of us was a
chili freedo would be you you seen your
hat have you seen your hair your hat
look like something I would wear turn it
in
dude I stole from Bobby Lee be cool man
did you really yeah I could see that a
little coming hot dude what's up bro
do I look like Chester cheeto oh yeah
you know old school is Chester cheeto
yeah is it same nose Guzzi yeah let's
pull him up man can we pull up Chester
cheeto hey chin you know Chester cheeto
is yeah Jen you look like a chili Frito
type of dude
yeah big ways barbecue baked Lay's baby
oh you meant [ __ ] in the sunshine
making them lazy you look like you know
what Nick Nick looks like a Funyuns guy
you think hey you have Funyuns in the
back your car not a funny guy well Nick
even took offense you know Funyuns guy
that the [ __ ] you say boy what oh I do
have the same nose it's just yeah you
look like just you know to be a bad
remember him
I remember saying I him Antonius yeah
somebody's had him in the tummy and the
tiger got enough fight brothers
basically y'all yeah yeah it is a little
Tony the Tiger and Chester the cheetah
yeah I like now I see I like a nice Dino
we're stuck on food cuz we're to the
Hellmouth thick our lower portions of
our body are the others don't match at
all
well these pants are so tight if your
jeans came in just struggle sick dude
yeah they feel bad limp loss I think I
need to get an IV for my cheek that
levees about to break brother I think
it's you came in the jeans off that's
the threading smuggling some [ __ ] if you
put your here so hard you can hear my
heart out video and wouldn't
why is your ass so swole these days yeah
I've been going to a trainer who's this
[ __ ] trail I need to see them dudes
car DB son yeah I got that cardi bottom
dude the the problem with me is one of
the problems is the the bottom half of
my body looks different than the top
half of my body it looks like my top
half is me and the bottom half is like a
rental no it's like no trips top how I
feel top half soccer-mom bottom half
just a [ __ ] NFL running back wait
you're a fullback for the Steelers yes
and big haunches
it's getting pic down here dude are you
sorry giving a lot of attention on the
streets mmm
no you don't the see you pregnant paying
attention to it first of all I don't
want people see me for having a big butt
dude I already have a very unique look
it's the last thing I need and also I
beat down syndrome a lot of people know
that and so this is one of the side
effects don't hold that down but oh dude
them boys cut back pro bono growing up I
use hang out with black and had a black
girl with Down syndrome in our school
name clarinet first a second name
clarinet not clarinet clearing that yeah
and people would always make us be on
the same team for everything I bet dude
she's cool clarinet and ruffles let's
get at it'll ruffles double ruffles with
that [ __ ] ass you know little ruffles
yeah yeah that's weird man you can't
wash jeans you can't wash jeans yeah one
wash yeah I got to get my jeans away
Doug well I feel like I I feel like uh
actually screw all you guys have big
asses dude everybody's big city big ass
nation mr. Peter is still growing those
Prima cheeks bro I feel left out we'll
go to deals trainer rope and see what we
can do then do my I feel like my skins
are big it's a bit like it's gonna
[ __ ] sneak up on my now boy you're
asking a rock dude I feel like
somebody's picking my ass up I like a
string and just pulling it up into the
air really got a move dude you ever seen
that hippo you're seeing the hip on
Madagascar get out the water
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
children family big asses big and chunky
did not oh you almost had Down syndrome
and I just slipped out of his they left
you the good stuff boys half in and half
out if flares up dude if you see me
waiting for a school bus if I'll tell
you this if seven school buses drove by
the short ones always would stop for me
dude they'd always be like you ready you
come on you don't like no wait I said no
I'm on a big one and the lady would look
at me are you sure honey yeah yeah and
she usually asked me a times table or
ask me an addition table and if I got it
right you say alright keep it on your
toes yeah good luck out there but do you
also look like [ __ ] runnin years I don't
forget that Brennan looks like every
buck and big girl that works at a snow
cone sale
like oh you wanna can this milk on net
that's so disc what do you want Tigers
blood ruffles listen bro listen little
rice
listen ruffle baby
what's this Joon don't think we forgot
about your flat ass either zero zero
janessa staples jeans together his shirt
he could be one of those cornhole games
he just let his head he just aim for his
bottle
Oh place Kiba in here's just a central
beach up it's easy let's make some
cobbler rough bro we got super Lacy and
we got on that in today welcome back cat
look lovely today I got a tan huh yeah
did you do hard I went to the beach wow
it's crazy you went to the beach and
Brennan's dress like a [ __ ] gay
second pass Grateful Dead grateful bread
brother would like this money wouldn't
like that vibe man he really would I
can't remember if I thought this huh or
if if I read this on somebody said
Brenda looks like Anna guy he goes dude
if I was counting I would find you first
the kid oh man I'm sweating it's hot in
there now you're right
dude it's hot in my pants let's get into
it man
what is that Nick this was some
reconnaissance work our editor Joe did
shadow but I don't know you just found
some of Chappelle's cheer career oh man
oh hell that's watching us I don't care
I mean you got it up now it says
tumbling and cheer is that two different
things what is it yeah like tumblings
just like just a gymnastics park on the
map is that what you were tumblr mmm-hmm
well I was I did bow that was a stumble
okay all right
yeah because I was a popular season two
years old and she was doing I was like
hey disrespect before I've probably
never noticed it the only person here
this dress like they still have a best
friend is know what's going on I don't
know I didn't make this video this
seemed like part of a taste
oh no my friend she did it for her
college project what's going on with
littles oh there was here
Oh is he good it was a good
wow man you gotta blow up the real
cheerleading of me man is this real
that's false yeah this is there no video
of you doing flips and [ __ ] yeah and you
know also George video George Bush
man wait oh now you got a fave now you
looking tight oh yeah let's see this
that's you there are these outfits for
American Pie to who know but I was
[ __ ] American yeah bro Oleg take
your house to Vegas like the stand-up
game dude I wish now don't you get dizzy
shorty want a thug who's that that's my
best friend Brooke still your best
friend yeah I got best friend city bro
you put on the wig [ __ ] fine that's
awesome you gotta get a B hey you know
we're going we got problems over here
dawg Wow Dan that's your best friend oh
yeah are you jealous - jealous
oh she's married has a kid oh you guys
are best friends but but not when you
guys were cheering she did not know any
did you did I what have a did you did
you have a girlfriend when you were
chairing no my first yamo you this this
Nucor this this girlfriends your first
girlfriend ever
Tiffany what's her name I bet you're
beating them off with a stick as a
cheerleader though am i right yeah
that's a thing that weren't you around a
ton of women went with it with
cheerleader would seem like there's just
a ton of women right there there is yeah
and I bet you had some fun and I don't
like to I don't like the you don't kiss
and tail
yeah
you don't flip and tell have you ever
have ever been a pregnant girl you could
lift up or just non-pregnant there was
one girl that didn't know she was
pregnant
oh she was tumbling around and [ __ ] yeah
she was a mom well I mean she ended up
you know did you have the baby
yes yeah that's what happens well not if
she's trembling and doing flips and [ __ ]
and probably lost the kid
well can't do all that shake the kid hub
there yeah shake shake grandma roll
kicking out somersaulting I think it
came out breech do double breech double
back breech no baby good Matt talk dude
I can't get enough cheer that new show
yeah I finished it I haven't seen it yet
you should check it out what are you
guys watching what are the Vietnamese
community watching right now I've been
watching cheer I also finished watching
you and The Witcher on Netflix how good
is you know delusion you two haven't
gotten there yeah I'm selling see I just
finished season one I don't know the
main character really like that much
he's like uh I don't know he's like yeah
I don't know I I go off and on him he's
sound like a shitty Dexter I don't think
you're supposed to completely yeah you
right just an agreeing so quick so legit
point do you know flamingos can have
almost eleven children at once can you
look that up here do you know why
flamingos are pink yep why because the
one of the reasons is they need they
need other penguins to see them at night
I'm not a penguin but because the food
date whether it's the shrimp YZ they
they the the food that day is pink so
their bodies opinion yeah that's your
job bro yes you specifically I mean you
can't see it on-screen
I think flamingos are yeah but how about
some may be information [ __ ] oh man
what's the last time you're shaving your
junk you thought you know what man it's
just isn't worth anymore it's too much
of a hassle I keep cutting my nutsack
it's exhausting I'm just gonna grow
often it's exhausting dude or the
you got to get your fitness up man it
looks like Jumanji down there does it
it's too much too much work dude I wish
there's some sort of there is Brandon
grooming product like well there is man
all right tell me about it there is it's
called manscape Wow and look it's
forever changing the grooming game they
have the perfect package 3.0 essentials
kit it's new and it's the perfect
perfect amount of tools and what you
need to tighten up your sexual area wow
dude
oh yeah man dude and it also comes with
a crop preserver anti chafing ball
deodorant oh my god because people's
balls aren't doing well and they know
that at man they sweat too you know yeah
you forget about them dude your balls
need to be organized and manscaped helps
when you purchase the new perfect
package 3.0 kit you get the biggest bang
for your buck do get that banger for
your bulge get twisting off and free
shipping with the code cats at manscape
calm yeah you don't want your you know
you don't somebody putting a for sale
sign out on this out in front of your
wiener you know because they let people
haven't been taking care of the land you
know you don't you don't to braid the
hair in the front man no you don't want
to cornrow your wanker no get 20% off
and free shipping with the code Kay 80s
at manscaped dot-com 20% off with Free
Shipping at manscape calm use the code
Kay 80s your partner your body and your
balls will thank you and get your legs
to why yeah he look horrible
oh man look I'll tell you though I went
through three boxes of this in a week
because I loved it oh my god dude I've
been so dehydrated you know what they
sent me this I thought what is this and
then I read oh it hold up it's the
fastest most efficient way to stay
hydrated and your boy doesn't drink
water yeah I need this this is instead
of drinking if you you can still drink
eight glasses of water in a day or you
could just drink two glasses of liquid
IV I'm not saying it's exactly the same
but I am
and bro it makes you feel hydrated dude
if I have a liquid IV you pour it in the
cup mixed it in quick boom I can whistle
so much better because my whistle is wet
dude I want to wet my whistle yep one
stick in sixteen ounces of water
hydrates you two to three times faster
then more efficiently than water alone
bro liquid IV is the fastest-growing
wellness brand can find them everywhere
it's got bosco whole food you ever heard
of it dude yeah I've heard of it it's
got vitamin C vitamin b3 b5 b9 b 8b 6
b12 be ready beat your brother up you
can also get listen we take one liquid
IV it provides the same hydration as
drinking 2 to 3 bottles of water what
yeah I already said that
did you yeah man it's so crazy though I
had to double down on it because you got
a hydrate bro your brains
came out here liquid I lick what I've II
can provide the same hydration as
drinking two to three bottles of water
that's nuts
I'm glad you said that thank you twerps
off when you go to liquid IV commies
Code K ATS at checkout that's 20% off 25
thing 25 what did I say what did I -
hundred 200 no it's 25% off anything you
order on liquid Ivy's website let's go
to liquid I be calm enter promo code k
80s to save 25% and get better hydration
that's liquid IV calm promo code cats I
love this stuff man it got the perfect
amount of like a little bit of salt a
little bit of sweet a little bit of this
and that and boom salty sweet like on
your skin babe Oh bro it's like sucking
on your cousin brother good
oh what'd you do for Valentine's Day
dude what did I do to cry yourself to
sleep no not much man had a couple
chocolates did a Dateline there was a
new Dateline on thank God
it's like they knew people were gonna be
by themselves yeah you know box of
caramels little Dateline no what did I
have I did maybe get your cheeks out I
polished off some of those mochi says
mochi candy says Mochis frozen snacks as
snacks
oh are those the little discs with ice
cream in the middle and then they have
like almost uh wax or like a flower on
them they're Asian right there nice yeah
would you pack six yeah they had a pack
of eight I thought it was only six and
they had two in the back what again what
a gift what a night free oh god I have
three of them a pack of Mochis I had
three of them taste cigarettes and a
cigarette two cigarettes actually live
in the dream brother don't cry I'm not
yes sounds like way better mind it was
great man it's way better than having
somebody what about you Brendan I had to
work you did I got really sick yeah I
was working on Ontario super sick on
Valentine got through the shows but my
girl sunflowers she was at that
appreciative of them in cat newly single
what's it like to have a Valentine's Day
as a single woman it was cool I hung out
with my girlfriends and purposefully
stayed away from men Wow
I think it's weird cuz I got an offer to
go out on Valentine's Day but that would
have been a first day and I feel like
that's too much pressure do you want to
go out with the guy though I don't want
to go out with a guy I just want to get
to know people that's a yeah like I
don't want to really hang out hang out
but what do you want to do then like
grab food and then like go home by
myself afterwards yeah let them know
that you know let them know see if
they're interested doesn't yeah yeah no
no no they don't see man what kind of
man are these men we're talking about
we're talking man who talking boys can't
uh we're talking men I like older guys
Oh
fifteen talking to a dude that's 32
right now
except that all just a little older
older than me well right yes I didn't
get along dude she is what are you 22 23
24
oh my so 32 that's like you know Bernie
Sanders dur ya ya ya ya say you like him
older man can like guys can't there's no
play games have their [ __ ] together well
I see a white boy
no agent Wow hmm I'm just off on this
you going Asian huh even chin was
surprised he thought I was gonna go out
with the white guy I thought for sure
but you decide to go Asian well this one
yes but you saw me Chong it's not that
serious that's good that's really good
it's not that serious though it's not
that no and are you looking for anything
serious right now or not uh no that's
why you gotta take it slow with this you
want you want your your uncle's over
here uncle ruffles in little thick here
to interview wants to put them through
the grinder through the grinder we look
like [ __ ] steady and bebop you look like
your whole body went through puberty
except you got a Brazilian butt lift and
[ __ ] Albuquerque two-for-one
what's back there tamale I never talked
with your trainer telling her arms arms
she's my god you're good man just like a
Kermit the Frog ones save arms in your
butt we're building biceps in your ass
the anymore
even after shows people liked it
I'm so distracted with your I know well
you got a female trainer oh yeah I got a
few more trainer that's usually frowned
upon - yours looks like Fabio and she's
a female no he's a man a lot of uh this
woman is yeah decent lady her name's
Shannon she Hut
oh she's attractive girl if you got rims
tough man
but I find I work out better with a
female trainer because you playboy it
just makes me a little bit more I don't
know I
or maybe since her maybe just her but
she like puts down the she like there's
no BS him with her yeah you better get
after him yeah she puts it down yeah
there's no BS nothing and she's got you
pushing that sled with your ass out
monday-friday you know what it is just
squat how'd it is a lot of male trainers
have egos you think yeah bad ones though
if they're bad when there's some good
male trainers out for sure yeah yeah I
uh I don't this lady's she's kind of
she's pretty gangster she's pretty wild
I like them all I think there's good in
both yeah I like em all I needed it I
just need somebody to get me going
I don't do male masseuses though you
don't I can't relax dude I just can't
it's just like yeah it's just I don't
know I just can't I just can't get to
that spot sitting there with a shield
and a night like go for broke
I like them thighs them thighs I go get
that thigh massage bra and then thighs
I'll run up and down your back bro dude
dude or run across the room [ __ ] run
from across room and kick me in the
[ __ ] back who saved ties well done
thighs are tired tie-dye my massage
daddy bar yeah yeah yeah you gotta
finish like that at yeah I like that
and they always be real secretive to
each other too yeah they always talk to
each other in the language and you have
no idea what's going on you have no idea
at least some languages look like you
get a little bit of an idea yeah there
could be no idea you think that they're
saying bye and then the guy just takes
his eyeballs out of his head
but she goes on break and come back just
wait in there
yeah no pants on yeah you ever had that
you ever have ever are you do you have
no Hardee's at I Hardee's hey you ever
get those massages that it's you and
another guy in the room it's 2 and 1
you're at the head why can't they walk
on your back oh yeah I don't waste a
[ __ ] time well for $60 there's two
dudes they'll stand on your back and
start fighting each other downtown I'm
not even joking to Vietnamese dude hey
they told me so what do I go did he
unique oh this Russian spa and he go in
there and these guys beat you with these
[ __ ] sticks and then hit you with
honey and then douse you like was it you
chin what don't about you can be sound
like chance something chimp woman and
then douse you in water no not me it's
like what's wrong with this group every
time I look at you I feel like I have to
go to the dude who wants to play freeze
tag at summer camp
dude is always like when's lunch and he
just got there just drop them off yeah
we had a whole day winds launch
no more kickball wins lon you know
ruffles and winds live show together man
ruffles and wins lunch it sounds like a
uh it sounds like maybe something you'd
see in Japan or Chan or a new sitcom
here are new chickens to go and they
coming this fall so that's it what you
do on Valentine's I was in Houston oh
yeah
Oh Dan my girl and I celebrated when
when I got back yeah yeah I did a
staycation oh yeah
yeah vacations nice though right yeah
Hotel downtown what's down there Ace
Hotel that's where we start yeah yeah
work is pretty fun
mm-hmm had ramen oh no [ __ ] culture
yeah Nick would you do I think I think I
want to be asked one what Valentine's
Day out of anybody I don't see Oh sounds
fantastic
hey I don't know I mean for what they
did with the lady not for the people
were alone okay God but yes oh he took
his lady North thing yeah yeah yeah so
last week the night of the Super Bowl a
tree fell on my car
so directly on his car - we'll put the
photo in it yeah absolutely
he says it I thought he made it fake
he's like oh next trying to not work
literally a tree tree fell on top of
your car yeah yeah some from Tom and
Jerry's it's great and so anyways my
car's in the shop
so I got a rental and all they had left
was this of like the level I could
afford like the higher one was a Chevy
Chevy Camaro Convertible so I decided to
go up the coast to Santa Barbara with
the top down got a hotel had flowers and
the had roses in the hotel room when I
got there it was it was good mr. steal
your girl got the Camaro got the titties
out that's what they caught when you put
the top down I'm trying to be look at oh
[ __ ] just get a new car though you know
yeah they told it's totaled yeah I
haven't heard how much I'm gonna get
back from it I hope I don't get screwed
say you were in it dude say your neck
hurts and your Rolex broke do agree
agreed well now you can
bro that it's almost like you guys put
it there in that tree also has no roots
is that a real tree we on the universal
lock the thing likes fakest [ __ ] was the
route yeah this looks like where the
world's like it may be one of those I uh
things to get cell service maybe I could
I'm gonna sell you
one of those 18 trees it doesn't look
like it [ __ ] your car up too much
yeah I really doesn't follow I was
hopeful too but my girlfriend actually
she saw this at 4:00 in the morning I
woke up to pictures of it and they when
I got there at 11:00 the tree was gone
there's a pretty big done like they have
to replace the door and the hood it's
all it's just one big done when only
she's got a cool Camaro and a nice
Valentine's Day out of it yeah man yeah
you still made it work yeah how would he
a lot of men would have been like oh
[ __ ] cars down Valentine's is down I
just went to Jocko with the good yep
good good what else we got discipline
equals freedom dude that's right okay
Charcot sent me so much protein powder
maybe that sounds dude
Jocko has an ass bro I've never looked
at his ass oh dude all he goes back
there Oh Betty when he takes his pants
on like 11 Falcons just flat butt and
yell freedom dude he told me he once
tried to teach a aah
American Eagle to shoot a gun how crazy
that makes sense though yeah does
obviously Brendan and I need help
dude I'm just doing some better hell
yeah I and what I'm telling you is I
assume didn't solve everything zomling
the hard way dude yes I was down the
other day man that hat doesn't solve
anything for nothing dude oh my god I
feel like that hat matches with one of
my Grimm with one of my grandmother's
dishpan
but what we're here to tell you about
right now is that sometimes you need
help and you can't just get it from a
buddy or from a cousin or a step cousin
and that's what I'm talking about is
better hell yeah sometimes your stepmom
doesn't have all the answers dude nope
she sure does it find out the hard way
yep and buy this hat they recommend it
better help man better help is an online
learning basically it's an online
learning mental health place they see a
therapist where you don't have to go
into the office yeah FaceTime whenever
you want
dude I was losing my mind
one day up over there out for the
interstate and I saw pulled over got
onto my better help account
boom boom boom next thing you know I'm
facetiming with my therapist with with
the counselor it helped out huh right
there yeah settle down got it together
can log on anytime yeah he's gonna
message your counselor yep you get
timely and thought thoughtful responses
plus you can schedule weekly video or
phone sessions so you won't ever have to
sit in on uncomfortable waiting rooms
traditional therapy enough to do all
that man ya better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so then make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed better help wants
you to start living a happier life today
there's a broad range of expertise in
their counselor Network which you may
not have locally available in your area
visit better help calm /ke 80s that's be
tter h ELP and join the over 700,000
people taking charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional that's K 80s for you guys
better help that calm / K 80s there's a
special offer freaking this thing
listeners as well you get 10% off your
first month at better help calm / Kate
and get that help baby get that help get
your mind right what I'm here to tell
you about guys say you have a bunch of
stuff in your apartment you can't get
rid of it right there's no way you don't
have it you don't have you can't get it
downstairs to the trash or whatever mail
it to someone and whether you're just
mail and junk to someone or whether
you're selling quality goods online
getting your orders out should only be
done one way and that is shipstation
it's a good way to keep track of who
gets what and which shipping carrier you
should use so I was trying to ship
something man I'm so tough no worries I
was just saying you can use all the
shipping carriers us I thank the Lord no
matter what I'm selling Amazon
my own whatever I'm some my website ship
station brings you all your orders into
one interface this is that stood yeah do
you think they can ship you a new wig is
it a wig and Porsche
Heys I'm working again they should be
some new hair books Oh sleepaway camp
called and you're been missing
apparently okay big father-daughter
dance
hey do they want you back hey those wigs
are us deliver they sure do
the you're more of the lesbian out back
no wonder shepley's the number one
choice of online sellers you [ __ ] more
in less time with the best rates
available and right now Kingston misses
can try shipstation free for 60 days
when use the code k ATS there's no risk
you start free trial without even
entering your credit card ship what's up
ship station works with all the major
carriers including USPS FedEx UPS even
Amazon's fulfillment all of them dog
just visit cheetah station comm click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in cats that ship
Stacey Dawber code kts ship station calm
ship happy we got a question right here
what is this note yesterday today does
long intro but we got some King in a
sting some debate club clown my hound if
we get to it and our new segment about
up in people's tinder profiles which I
know we could decide the the name of the
segment on air we had some a lot of
submissions there was like one
resounding favorite but I don't know if
you guys had any suggestions for it what
was the what was the cinder my tinder
was overwhelming favorite okay makes
sense we torch the profiles build them
from the ground up there was also style
my profile singed my hinge hmm I also
saw shiver me tender tender done I think
it's it's fun so yeah I think and I
don't know if we can help him where we
can definitely say look does don't do
this you know I think [ __ ] would like to
help them I think we can help them yeah
that's what I mean I was gonna say
I was gonna save it till the end but
since that was such a long intro let's
get right to it first we got suck suck
was 22 years old oh well we got change a
day huh oh damn this is the kid from
he's the bad guy in venom he's also in
that the HBO series I think he looks
like that movement trainer II don't
IDO portal dude I think sucks doing a
nice job here yeah I don't think he
sucks at all yeah he's climbing the wall
there's a wall climbing there is him
with sunglasses on looking cool looks
like he has a coconut water or his
recently had one mmm he has toplessness
and he has wet body his body looks wet
it's very wet apparently works out and
there's one with him and um who's that
guy Carson Daly yeah
pear that some sort of Casa Bonita
Mexican restaurant and he looks like a
very friendly dude and he's Mexican yeah
yeah I'm sorry I met Indian I was
staring at the the Mexican guy when I
said this sucker is an Indian name
that's just suck dude no it isn't you
think it's sucker you think the hottest
sucker sucker sucker so dude I'm Tony he
looks like the bad guy then and then his
written profile says carefully written
fact checked essay in the streets on
moderated comment section in the streets
any inflation cliche - creepy - cliche -
Ryan me the girls my god I like it that
makes sense
- Ronnie you think too much it's too
much oh it's like he's it's like he's
pitching us ideas for another segment
idea we got a rhyme everything dude
we're not even gay man dude Kat what do
you think how are we knowing I mean I
know dude photos are good I think the
bio could use a little work what do you
think about the more human in the bio
man there's not regular this shirt
gym selfie like that seems like just go
to the beach get a natural picture with
your shirt yeah this is creepy no one
likes a guy who gets done working out
that takes up selfie in the mirror or
body yeah boys watered up probably out
of the steam room yeah and that's not a
real workout if heat has been in the
steam room Roman and what wait what to
say my anthem the [ __ ] his anthem to
play a song now uh yeah you can connect
it to your Spotify oh wow and can we
here's a song include it in the picture
um
but look he's climbing the wall right
there obviously is a active I would say
Kratts yep I would say get some pictures
with some puppies some dogs chicks dig
dogs dude and their outdoor activities
he's got that outdoor one right there
that's indoor that's rock-climbing
yeah it's indoor right it's outdoors
indoors I feel you it's outdoors into
where I was going yeah it's like when
you see like a lot of plants indoors his
profile needs more real [ __ ] like
carefully written fact-checked essay in
the streets on my comment section in the
sheets he looks like he's awesome danger
too equally looks like he could be
someone who does danger from another
country as well yeah I get that vibe as
well it also looks like you're being
don't [ __ ] with cats part but you mean
like parkour yeah yeah yeah I recorded
yeah like parkour he definitely seems
like he could be good-looking dude you
shouldn't have too much problem 22 it
seemed like he would be like the bad guy
and like a lot of Trump campaign that's
fair uh but no look man I don't know I
don't I'm not trying to meet women out
here you know I I don't have any idea
and I'm not a woman I don't know I think
I do man yeah make you seem more
friendly more and more relatable that
that weird [ __ ] you got written in your
bio ain't gonna work homeboy yes
pictures dogs you're the picture of you
in the gym right when you get done
working out no one likes that guy he
just seems a little too calculated that
does seem approachable yeah he's up dude
he's up dude yeah maybe have one of you
dancing with
one maybe have one of you building
something making like a you know just
doing model cars or doing like a donk
yeah building something outdoors fair
enough
I think that's a good start and I think
to kind of improve the segment we could
have people include all their pictures
and send in a video saying like what
their experience has been on tinder what
they're looking yeah how's it been going
yeah yeah yeah because you're 22 I don't
think it's struggling to skinny titties
in his mouth I'm not sure I mean I'm not
attracted to the guy yeah I don't
this isn't gender we're not trying to
match you up with suka okay okay like I
might get you something what a great
name ah let's get lucky some king of
saying it's I don't know if we helped
suck her or not look you're making a
smart move Chappell I agree this man's
being wild and here comes a guy it's
time for King understood
[Music]
the hockey
[Laughter]
give me Wayne Gretzky's playing up the
[ __ ] Street alone nine dumbasses I
have no clue and the team's called like
the Long Island Dragon this is the
Ontario rain York Rangers played up the
street I'm Brian I get a go dude [ __ ]
you
you don't want to go see some really
something Larry Allman the solid players
in these under league teams man you got
to get out there brah Chester pine you
don't know a lot of hockey everybody's
play like [ __ ] happy you just slap
shot it can't skate frozen Ronnie Harper
you know a lot of these [ __ ] players
they have out there dude even mexican
players bro I saw that it's called
disney on ice
mickey fells like dude you gotta get out
and about more they have unique names
bro come on brother tacoma laundry the
goalie ramela row they have all kind of
cool names root the roanoke skittles
they got fun names dude they even have a
all gay women's team Ohio little dead
easy money is a stanky walk
Tigger's thing at number two
hey guys Chris from Long Beach king it
or sting it seeing an xml game live game
gay buzz buzz a great video that's a
great clean video in the audience
fantastic dude it's tough enough to get
me to watch the [ __ ] la ramps up the
street I hate going to the LA shuffle or
the [ __ ] they are man I'm not doing it
I'd rather see prisons play each other
dude honestly like The Longest Yard yeah
I'd rather see me into that yeah you
ever gotten to the the when the cops and
the firefighters fight each other
do that for blood brilliant yeah and you
get a black cop and a white firefighter
wow what are they fighting for freedom
this is real yeah yeah cops were
firefighters a real like competition and
when it gets in New York it's like
serious [ __ ] yeah there's always like
one real bruiser on each team it's great
dude what about my we didn't get coal
tomorrow what do y'all think about the
minor-league hockey really nope
oh there are no Asian hockey players are
there never never
oh no uh there was a guy named Korea
what's his name who's Korea snow Asians
Yeah right it snows in Japan they got a
nice and like do tricks and [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah yeah Gucci yep Kristi Yamaguchi
yeah he played for the Anaheim Ducks I
think really Korea new generation of
asian-american hockey players but it was
Korea with like KY iara or some [ __ ]
like that views phenomenal player Wow
and what was it the XFL a la I think
seeing it live you Nick went I did I did
how was it you go back Nick I I think
I'd go back if I got free tickets but it
was like for the energy in the stadium
for the first
la it was actually impressive like like
you said it was really loud in there and
I just got to kick out other people
there were people decked out in la
Wildcats gear and they were just like
decided day one this is their teams
people aren't that Batman's just looking
for something to cheer for
but the football was really really so
bad I'd watch like a half on TV it that
the fundamentals the execution the score
was like six to nine awful what's bad
about it like is they're just not I mean
just draw NFL rejects drop drop balls I
mean middle of the second quarter in
that video is zero zero I mean they're
just they just can't score and stuff I
don't know it was it was kind of rough
they have some fun stuff like you can do
pit for extra point you can pick one two
or three points from the two five or ten
which like at the end of the games gets
really interesting they're really
sucking up the score and stuff like
could have ended it with a three I don't
know some strategy that possibly the NFL
could adopt they got cheerleaders
yeah there were cheerleaders out there
okay all right I respect do not really
mm-hmm
those cheerleaders out there as well are
there male cheerleaders to the LA Rams
have two male cheerleaders I've seen
them Chabal no more dancers bro do what
I do
fellas dancers not only they do what you
do but they're doing at the highest
level Bravo
yellow champs the world champs they're
not world I promise I saw him on 9news
who is abducting world champs they're
two black guys type in LA Rams male
cheerleaders threw the first ones ever
like are they dancing with a cheerleader
know something dude they'll do it all
hmm George Bush there they are right
there first - that's them right there
bro on there's your brother the middle
guys definitely the data to do the
taptic job pants on your dick the middle
guy
he will meet you
wherever you want to be he looks like
Michael yo he does it I'm Michael yo
dude looks like Michael yo where's your
[Laughter]
jacket man you seem like a nice guy dude
their users with his with his buddy
game man cheerleaders it's LA you can
have everything no it's just America
dude yeah yeah but la is always at the
forefront we gotta have you know a gay
male cheerleader we gotta have somebody
who you know we have the first
illiterate cheerleader
you know coach or whatever you know we
got somebody with no eyes and no years
video of the City Council we got
somebody moonlights as a bowling ball
you know say you got all kind of people
we have somebody was born without a
digestive tract and Madeline yeah
they're dancers that's not what I did
the backgrounds like I'm sorry what are
we doing
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] what am i laughing here's our boy
Matt West I'm from Pacifica from PBR
professional bull rider I've got that
what's up guys Matt West voice of the
PBR Professional Bull Riders are here
gunner I recognize your singing gang
buzz buzz interesting what your type
[ __ ] shirt dude western dudes do not
have a lot of extra fabric on them all
right gasps spice club Oh what's this
question though the PBR was that Dallas
AT&T stadium for the global cop he said
qinger sting at Pro Bowl riding cowboy
we know what you two we will bring the
video look just cuz I'm built like a
Minotaur from the waist down
she kept people trying to tie your nuts
and ride you I [ __ ] with it it's cool
again I wouldn't go why wouldn't you go
I don't care to watch men ride bulls I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't want to watch
that I don't want to watch that [ __ ]
shitty minor-league hockey game I don't
watch the weird football you wanna chill
man just go right a sheep all goddamn
afternoon yeah but who's that NBA
announcer that smokes a lot of weed the
older guy oh well yeah oh but Bill
Walton want you to dress up like his
little twink I see what's a grateful
Brad bro
I heard it's cinnamon amazing
I gotta say I think you would love PBR
we should take a group trip when they
come back to Anaheim no recontour PBR
they're all have boyfriends but there's
a left I'm saying they're all with these
rough Cowboys shape like [ __ ] Tim
McGraw over here dude when you see the
crowd everybody's just sitting like this
shirt with the collar up to here you
can't even see it's just the same person
everywhere Oh men and women I wish your
terrorist is trying to [ __ ] pull the
gun out there lit up like Yosemite Sam
and that [ __ ]
oh yeah there's no joke bro you put even
if you just let it dove loose in there
somebody I'm gonna date white I think it
shot yeah if you got a great uh that
doves a little [ __ ] It's A Wrap dirty
game set man let's go to the culture
corner what do you guys think bull
riding how what's going on with the
what's bull riding in the black
community's a popular Chappelle no come
on now well there's some black bull
riders there are some black bull riders
but I don't think it's like popular you
know I mean there are some black hawk
people yeah there's some black hockey
players there's some black XFL players
there's some black cheerleaders yeah we
got them all but I mean I don't think
it's like it's not what I'm do growing
up do you remember there being some bull
riding brothers kind of out there no I
was like the odd man out cuz I was like
skateboarding and playing guitar and
stuff like that so there was like yeah
across the board so like I don't know
just stuff outside of the black
community stuff like that it's probably
not like all right I'll do it
cat would you go I would go VIN amis
people don't ride bulls we do ride water
buffalos
similar see now we talk and not so much
water buffalo dangerous so you write it
in the sense of like that not like that
boy oh you run through the water yeah
through the water okay
water buffalo super dangerous it's like
a taxi so you guys use it as a mode of
transportation yeah sometimes but you're
not you're not hitting in it's nuts to
see if you can hang on for eight seconds
here we are i dancing for eight hours
here's some laotians right here riding
up w baby that's what it is it's Laos
isn't it yeah this is stalled out I feel
like they would have some great black
bull riders though I'm think wha there's
like one really good one right I don't
know I mean I think he's I think he's
right I just don't know anything I don't
know anything about bull rider I put it
but I would go watch I'm not like on
this guy's team I'd watch it I think you
dope to see yeah I don't like I just
want to go watch it for an afternoon you
think that you could ride longer than I
could on a bull
yeah probably dude I mean your ass what
do you mean my ass you know if this hit
way up on the front of the bull what's
the place by the family store let's do
this
oh yeah what is that ranch ranch at
around the mechanical bull yeah
mechanical people you breaking their
necks and [ __ ] on that thing
big fat drunk [ __ ] get on them like
dude that thing has caused many a
miscarriage bro I think miscarriage is
the Bulls name too soon too soon too
soon
what's their sleeve it's a method of
travel I guess that's true I guess I
have seen like especially photos where
there's people on water buffalo mm-hmm
but dude that water buffalo is sharp
horns there you see the horns on that
water buffalo is super dangerous you
talk to cam Haines he says the most
dangerous animal that they like can [ __ ]
with when they run in Africa's a [ __ ]
Buffalo really we smell like dead water
buffalo yeah hippos kill more people
than any land mammal I knew that mmm-hmm
cuz you're a book yeah mmm ruffles the
hippo what else you got Nick we haven't
done this one for a while we got some
clown my hound and I took note that the
bag on that beagle other things got nut
here we gonna play catch in smile
possibility cab I know what happened oh
he's that was sent in by Jess John what
you do is this man play it for me one
more time I didn't realize the other I
thought it was enough it's like a bat
he's a dog from the top up it could be
bad at the bottom blame it on them
because you can't handle yourself don't
blame it on them because things are too
busy at the smoothie Shack wherever you
work and you look like the only human in
Mario Kart that's uncomfortable [ __ ]
the animal fused legs man
yeah let's go to you
in the in the Asian community and I'm
sorry this dog's name is Aria not Simba
Aria Aria beautiful animal and I think
it looks like a pitbull ball yeah it's a
pitbull with a sack on them and some bat
wings on the bottom well here's the
thing it was startling the mini because
I thought it was all nuts down there I
thought it was I didn't know that it had
legs that have fused up mm-hmm
and I guess it could have been from what
being on something hot or something how
does this even happen it was he born
like this moving that way or maybe like
a car ran over them his backside but
don't look like he's mangled looks like
he's badging pretty well with it well
sort of scooters on the bottom yeah yeah
yeah and be honest with me in the live
or die yeah dude
the vet is a restaurant okay not in a
bad way but we've all had a life you've
ever been in Vietnam
you've had a little bit of hound brother
and that's for damn sure I see all those
dogs with all the wheels on it though
huh bro them dogs out those off-road
wheels on them via the forum yes some of
these dogs have very one of them look
like a damn ten speed look at that one
yeah one of them had like a mountain
bike structure on the rickshaw right
there look a little rickshaw the other
one was for drag racing yeah that one's
built for down there look at that what
has in line yeah nope
at some point look at this another legs
he's just lazy some please go put these
things down right dude I'll take a room
I'll take that oh wow it to arms awawa
that's it stupid brave as hell look at
this one jumping over that [ __ ] stick
dude you tell me this isn't fun or than
a normal [ __ ] dog with four legs
that's true let's get one for the studio
I want that too leg [ __ ] a rollercoaster
buy that pitbull bat [ __ ] half pup
have post mates bro this thing can't
fetch you a bag of chips dude then I
don't know why could my god Rottweiler
half huffy bro man yeah you're Dotson's
got a flag this is amazing a lot of dogs
out there living the high life with
these with these uh with these back
wheels I celebrated you see a lot of
animals like this in the and your
community growing up I grew up in
Arizona you guys need to give us some
damn culture you came in walk dogs out
there during the summer right no oh now
that's true yeah thirty degrees yo the
lobby was a little rubber socks
yes but shoes on them like such a rubber
CI so they can't like really like 128
consumer the news has like warnings now
yeah what do you think dogs were doing
before we had them inside living outside
dead no now people putting [ __ ] tires
on them and [ __ ] dude sound asphalt like
I mean if it's a coyote it's living down
the mountains and yeah that that [ __ ]
black tar asphalt yeah put some converse
on your dog some cons on that little
hound what else you got Nick what else
you got Nick Jesus first we'll close it
out with some debate club did we answer
a question what were we supposed to do
do they want to know if they want to put
the dog down or not is that the question
oh my god I don't know what the show is
if you guys found it pretty well I think
mission accomplished trying to help and
look I'm just saying in some cultures
man a dog is a food that's fine meat is
a meat that's if a person dies I feel
like in some cultures aletheia facts you
know you got to have what you can have
you don't need a defender dude if I'm
dyin bro I'm eating you ask first I felt
that in my conversation that's how alive
I still AM I could feel it when you said
don't say it like that again so I mean
that's a lot yeah feed the whole goddamn
true all right hey guys this is Ashley
from New Jersey in honor of President's
Day weekend I have to bait Club for you
who was a better president Honest Abe
Lincoln or I cannot tell a lie
George Washington gang gang buzz buzz
you know what I'm gonna say
I was just happy to be here right now
I appreciate y'all I hope y'all choose
the right answer ready set go
[Laughter]
who was a better president than she's
saying
boy Honest Abe man you know what's weird
about Honest Abe is there's no record of
his voice but we all think it's seven
scores and seven you know super low yeah
they have no idea what it is some people
think it was really high just the movies
made it really low I think Abe I don't
know man a well here's the thing about
George you'd be the first president you
had to wear a wig and wooden teeth ha
and also super racist but was he raises
you think oh yeah was he he's just what
they did back then yeah you know dude do
you think you would have owned a slave
back then or posi you know growing up
yeah I don't know I don't I got to go
Abe yours Abe Abe also a vampire killer
was he's really a did you ever seen the
movie phenomenal movie Abraham Lincoln
vampire killer I've never seen it you
know it catch the rerun on FX oh god yes
I start [ __ ] living dude yeah going
to [ __ ] PBR and AFL games where the
hell it is and start watching TV
yeah Honest Abe was a PBR fan this
wasn't literally a guy in the crowd at
the Pro Bowl right Amen brother at Abe
right there huh Oh taking in some beer
odds right there baby
you purposely dressed like Abe Lincoln
well that's just his vibe I think that's
him that's him yeah Wow he's got to be
somewhere dude I'll get your own eye you
put his head back together show an
identity bro bro he got uh look I'll say
this man I've been honest Abe's home
that he lived in in Illinois they
actually preserved their whole
neighborhood the neighborhood that he
liked yeah they preserve so you can walk
around like his neighborhood and all the
houses are from like wasn't he like the
AC on five or six six two tall and had
that hat he was Dikembe Mutombo back
then yeah and he would keep his notes in
his hat he would keep notes in special
documents in his hat it was gangster
yeah and he had a lot of cats and he
would pet the cats all the time at home
they said I don't like he said it was a
little suspect yeah the way he really
had a lot of cats India the more you
know what eppley aid based on the cast
due to the cat look it was a visionary
man Abe I think you gotta go wave I
guess I think it just of a was a little
more also like five dollar bills more
than one you feel me haha done hey what
do you guys say there in the booth huh
Abraham Lincoln hey I should pal here
you don't hear a lot about George
Washington getting forgot about you a
lot about the old George Washington
these days doing well dude somebody just
they just somebody just spray painted a
bunch of graffiti on Plymouth Rock
yesterday they said yeah that's
offensive
that's crazy your boy a drunk he's he's
all been our face man Daniel day-lewis
played on yeah who was the last place in
that played George Washington maybe
Frank Caliendo maybe Plymouth Rock
vandalize house they're not security
around that [ __ ]
I know are we doing inside job come on
now yeah you right
you said it look like what they spray
panel I get dick on or something dicks
is always some go to ship for people it
is
yeah they spray those dick son stuff
right my off on that no you're right
yeah that's what there's a man in
Arizona right now that's like
spray-painting dicks on all the walls oh
yes yeah somebody spray-painted on it to
rock well the rock is one of several
monuments around the Plymouth waterfront
and what did they somebody wrote
something on it what they write on there
oh and they put some love some blood
yeah they just trying to add a little
color to it you know yeah put a damn
wolf by it or something they can't get
something to guard the damn rock little
Rottweiler on wheels next that [ __ ] yeah
yeah and look if you have a dog that's
still on four legs Brock you gotta
tighten your game up they have dogs out
there on two legs rolling on 11 all
wheel drive what else we got Nick that's
it yeah I was laughing so much I don't
know what happened really
all I remember is some dogs big old nut
oh that's it and then him having bat
wings and I'm flying around the lawn
dude a lot of all I remember this
episode well Brendan a lot of animals
are starting to be cross pollinated and
stuff so right it wouldn't be crazy to
see a bad a bad dog you know down the
future you know make sense but we'll see
man we'll see dog wait you got you
anywhere this weekend homeboy yeah oh I
got some dumb going to the Nashville I
got some show a show March I think maybe
the 17th or something I'm not sure
fun or April 17 at the Ryman in
Nashville should be pretty cool and
those tickets are going on sale this I
think this week
and what else that's it man I mean I'm
coming to some other places but it sold
out I'll see you soon love it man
I'm in took I'm in Vancouver Friday one
night only for jfl and the next week I'm
in Tacoma and then March I do a theater
run I'm in New Orleans hometown New
Orleans Detroit Toronto Minneapolis I
think that Atlanta and Kat has a new way
we can submit videos to the show what's
okay before we go from now on we're
gonna be taking submissions through
email and through social media so if you
post a new submission for a segment go
ahead and tag King the scene put a
hashtag for the segment so hashtag
debate club hashtag chide my ride
hashtag shiver me tender and we'll go
ahead look through them and we're
officially taking submissions through
social media cuz you guys have been
asking for it keep it under a minute try
to do it landscape and not vertical and
yeah gentlemen Instagram wall Twitter
post whatever those will take priority
over once sent in via email gang man and
where can we see you as Chappelle are
you performing anywhere coming up UConn
unless tomorrow Reno Reno are you
something Reno Tahoe some casinos yeah
I'm breech to pound some shows with me
though yeah Reno's wild man Reno is a
place it's yeah I wouldn't get I
wouldn't accept blood and Reno I'd give
it but I wouldn't accept no Mason it's
that kind of place yeah but it's coming
back it's bouncing back I don't know if
it ever left you feel me
it did I don't know if you ever got
started it used to be like the
automobile capital a little of not the
world but of like really entire make his
outfit look better at the last fix my
hair dude yeah dude
the hairs fine are you digging there
your brother's gonna appreciate this
[ __ ] oh you will love that shirt man
you love the gravy baby
God it is a it's a tip so you're looking
lean are you yeah my I don't know
alright alright we get out all right
thanks cat thinks today thanks Chappelle
chin Nick next time okay see you guys